two years ago i did a quick search on
youtube to try to figure out how to grow
a youtube channel without the use of any
other social media websites and you know
what i found
nada since then nimmin has answered the
question will my youtube channel grow
even if i don't promote my channel on
social media his answer was a resounding
yes and coming from someone who has
grown a youtube channel without the use
of any other social media websites and
is now monetized thanks to your support
i thought that i would share some of the
things that i think worked for me that
helped me as well as some of the things
that i did wrong
so that hopefully you don't make the
same mistakes if you're thinking of
starting a youtube channel without using
other social media websites because it's
definitely possible and it happened for
me to make sure you stick to the end of
the video because it's going to be
packed with information i'm going to be
giving you tons of tips and lessons that
i've learned throughout this process to
help you whether or not you have a
social media account but before we begin
if you like this video please give it a
thumbs up and help support my channel
and if not by all means thumbs it down
but please give me some feedback in the
comments so that i know what to work on
so grab yourself a cup of tea or your
latte and let's get started the first
and foremost thing that i believed
helped me grow my channel is that i had
it very clear in my mind that behind
this screen right here is a human being
with value and dignity and that because
of that i need to provide value and hold
respect for the people that watch my
videos when i film i picture talking to
a friend a person with a name and just
knowing and remembering that when i'm
filming katie or paul is watching really
helps me be more comfortable in front of
the camera because now i'm not just
talking to an inanimate object i'm
talking to a human being i'm talking to
a friend and as weird as it probably
looks and sounds i do a lot of
pretending i pretend as i'm talking to
my audience while i'm folding the
laundry washing the dishes or while i'm
on my way to work i tell you about my
journey to work and that cone that
jumped out at me it was the cone not me
i stand by that it was the cone
so basically i do a lot of talking to
myself and also one of the things that
i've practiced a lot is hand gestures
and what do you do with these things and
where do you put them because for
somebody who had struggled with social
anxiety for years body language did
definitely not come natural to me if you
feel uncomfortable in front of the
camera i highly recommend talking to
yourself in front of the mirror or even
just pretending like you're vlogging
even at the grocery store talk about how
you're gonna pick the best cantaloupe
and even better if you can record
yourself saying random things but you
know just practice vanessa van edwards
and her content on body language has
been a huge help to me so i highly
recommend that you check out her youtube
videos or her book captivate if you feel
like you need some help on body language
whether on or off camera because i think
that it definitely makes other people
feel more comfortable when you feel
comfortable with your own body language
but another way that picturing a friend
helps me is that it keeps into
perspective the what and why i'm doing
what i'm doing because even though i
don't post on a weekly basis like the
youtube gurus say that i should as a mom
as a business owner and as a nurse who
often ends up working overtime i
sacrifice things to be able to post
videos and sometimes
i just want to sleep in and when i get a
comment that a video was helpful or i
gained a new subscriber i remember that
i have a duty to fulfill and that i owe
it to my subscribers so i've said this
before
have a clearly defined why before we go
on leave a camera emoji in the comments
if you're starting your first youtube
channel this year yay
high five to you you got this and
secondly
just start just post if you haven't
started because you're like me and your
schedule is chaotic do what you can but
make it a scheduled date and have
specific times when you must post
undoubtedly your channel will grow much
faster if you do keep a consistent
schedule but if weekly is not doable for
you do what you can but don't let that
be an excuse not to start although it's
not so glamorous growing slowly is
better than never getting started or
dropping it all together
dealing with criticism as a beginner on
youtube
i really want to address criticism
because i feel like in the beginning you
may already have some doubts and so it
can be really easy to let hateful
comments bring you down so i want to
share with you some of the things that
worked for me so that criticism doesn't
stop you from doing the thing that you
want to do there have definitely been
times when i have felt doubt or felt
hurt after reading some of the comments
that are more destructive than
constructive in nature and in those
instances what i do is this little
exercise it sounds crazy but it works i
picture myself as a boat on the ocean
with no other boats around except maybe
you're not a boat you're a yacht yeah
big shiny yacht so picture this with me
you're on the water no other boats
around and when i feel those moments of
doubt creeping up i make this mental
picture in my mind and i tell myself
these words out loud if i am causing the
water to move then i am creating change
it means that i am moving and i repeat
this to myself out loud so that my brain
hears it loud and clear because what is
happening when a boat is on the water
and the water is staying still it's not
moving it's not going to any destination
it's not creating change if you will and
this is the same thing that happens when
you create change it creates waves it
ruffles people's feathers change makes
us uncomfortable it's outside our
comfort zone and our brains perceive it
as danger we're just wired that way so
when we watch people do something that
makes us feel uncomfortable it's a
natural human tendency for us to want
that to stop except some people just
don't go about sharing that in the
nicest way so here's a big tip that i
have for you if you're starting a
youtube channel or growing a youtube
channel no matter how colorful someone's
language may be in the comments
always give them the benefit of the
doubt and if you are going to respond
always be respectful in your response
because at the end of the day that's
your brand that you're representing i
was reading through the comments on a
diy youtube video and somebody had
commented on a better way to do
something and the youtuber responded
with well it's not like i could have dot
dot dot
i just cringed when i saw that because
first of all i didn't think that this
person meant it in a in a harmful rude
way but even if that had been the case
that's not going to entice people to
subscribe if anything people might
decide to leave because of that
defensive response don't get me wrong
i'm not saying to let people step all
over you but just be really cautious in
the way that you respond to everything
because it says a lot about you and your
brand and it's online forever i talk a
lot more in depth about criticism in my
video the three habits that are ruining
your life so check that one out for more
details on the topic because there's a
lot to be said here most likely you
won't start your channel with a defined
color palette a style of editing and
thumbnail design and searching through
other content creators work can be
really helpful to figure out what about
them you like what about their thumbnail
is catchy or the things that you don't
like and the things that you want to
avoid in your own work so for example i
actually started saying the by all means
thumbs it down in my intros because i
was subscribed to a finance youtuber who
just kept hounding people to hit the
like button and subscribe several times
throughout a video and it got to be a
point where i just felt like i was being
treated like a dollar bill and i felt
disrespected and i actually unsubscribed
because i was watching a video and i
think i must have heard it like four or
five times throughout that video and i
realized i don't want to do this to my
viewers and so i think that this is
where it can be really helpful to look
at other content creators work and see
the things that you want to do more of
and the things that you don't want to do
but when you consume content do not look
at it from a consumer's point of view
look at it from a creator's point of
view so change your perspective when
you're watching youtube videos just be
cautious that you don't fall into the
trap of wanting to be just like some
other youtuber because you've got
something that sets you apart and
whatever that something is will draw
people to you
adopt the mindset of a child who wants
to explore and try new things that's all
it is an experiment the more you
approach your videos from the aspect of
curiosity and let's try something
different the less pressure you'll have
and the more you'll learn along the way
and then if something does go wrong it's
okay because you learned a new way not
to do it i'm still figuring things out
but every video for me has been an
experiment and has taught me some lesson
in some way whether that was learning
how to do b-roll for the first time
doing a voice-over video trying out
different styles of music background
different topics
every video has taught me a new lesson
so don't be so hard on yourself when
people tell you they can't make it
through your video because the music is
too loud and distracting because you
couldn't hear it on your old riggity
laptop
it happens just make it your only goal
to improve on one thing with each video
and i assure you that as time progresses
and you continue to post you will
improve now let's talk about a biggie
equipment and setup this is where i
think i did some things right but
mainly i just made a lot of mistakes
first off let me tell you what i started
off with i had this sony camera that i
had purchased several years back i had a
laptop a tripod and a smartphone but
when it came to lighting i definitely
needed something to lighten up the home
and so what i did is i walked over to
the tool shed and i confiscated some of
my husband's work lights and this is
actually what i'm currently using and i
have been using ever since i started the
youtube channel so i considered this a
smart move using what i already had but
because i knew that i had a disadvantage
by not having other social media
websites i began to binge watch tons and
tons of videos on how to start a youtube
channel how to set up a background and
all those sorts of things and i began to
feel very inadequate when i saw other
youtubers gear and setup and the awesome
quality of their images and i began to
feel like i needed that to be able to
grow and so i ended up purchasing a very
expensive and large gimbal the zion
weeble lab and i mean this thing is
super awesome it's really very cool you
can't tell me this is not one sexy piece
of equipment it can produce some awesome
images
but
there's a big butt
i didn't consider my lifestyle when i
purchased it this one was a mistake for
me because for someone who works
full-time as a mom of two and trying to
start a youtube channel i don't have the
flexibility to take my camera from
tripod to put it on the gimbal and
balancing it and carrying this big thing
around while i'm chasing after my kids
it just does not work for me and so
sadly when i do use it
it's a tripod
a very expensive and fancy tripod if i
could go back i would have just started
with the zhiyun osmo 3 which i currently
do use for my smartphone footage because
of its compactness and portability and
because it has a built-in light and it
has a tripod stand i could just use this
as my all-over stand if i didn't want to
carry my camera around with me or if i
was going somewhere so i would have
definitely done my research more in the
beginning
or i would have just put this purchase
off for a later time because i don't
think that a gimbal was actually
necessary in the beginning so don't do
like me and buy things that you don't
need consider your lifestyle and whether
or not you're actually going to use
these things long term i think that some
people would consider it a mistake to
invest before you make any money because
when you
are making enough to be able to buy
equipment those purchases are a tax
deduction however in my case i consider
these next few purchases a smart move
even though i paid for them before being
monetized because they allowed me to
produce more content and better quality
content to be able to grow my channel
because while i don't think that you
need to have the best gear to start off
with if you have the means for it and
you intend to do this long term i
definitely think that it can be very
helpful to improve the quality of your
content so the first upgrade that i made
is that i swapped out my old samsung
smartphone which actually had like a
crack on the camera so that every image
that i made would have been kind of
blurry i mean it was enough to keep for
me but definitely not something that i
would have wanted to post online and i
swapped that out for my iphone 12 pro
max because it has a large storage
capacity and for me having the ability
to record 4k in my pocket is a game
changer because like i mentioned i'm a
very active mama and so it makes it to
where i don't have that barrier of being
able to film and i can just film some
b-roll wherever i am at any moment's
notice and even though you really don't
need fancy editing software i'm really
glad that i personally purchased final
cut pro because it makes the editing
process so much easier and faster for me
it makes it enjoyable i actually enjoy
editing and it makes it to where my
content is so much better i mean i dare
you to look back and try to figure out
where i got final cut pro because to me
there's like an obvious distinction like
you can totally tell oh she's got final
cut pro now and some other just minor
purchases that i think have been helpful
is just having a large capacity sd card
so that i don't have to worry about it
filling up while i'm filming um having
an extra battery because batteries love
to die when you get to the juicy stuff
and then just a remote which is totally
unnecessary but because it's just me
filming myself to smoic it helps me when
i want to start or stop recording or
have a timer so i can take the photos
for the thumbnails so my overall tip
when it comes to gear is first be
creative look around and see what you
already have or what you can rig up
second consider your lifestyle and
whether or not you will actually use it
long term and third consider your means
if you have the ability to do so and you
plan on using this long term then
purchase the things that will help you
make more and better content not
necessarily purchasing just for the sake
of having fancy equipment so those are
just some of the lessons that i've
learned and things that i've found
helpful in growing my channel i thank
you so much for your support and to you
my subscribers i always knew that when i
became monetized i wanted to do a
devoted video like where 100 of proceeds
from it was for charity and
kind of like a fundraiser sort of thing
and i've got some ideas i'm i'm thinking
about it and so hopefully that can
happen soon if you like this video
please give it a thumbs up and subscribe
so that you won't miss when i post a new
video and leave your suggestions down in
the comments below i can't wait to hear
from you and see you in the next video
smartphone smartphone currently do use
for my smartphone smart moan smart phone
that went out for mo
what
you